ok inciso b una celda nueva de zinc aire
es pesada en una balanza analítica antes
de colocarla en un aparato auditivo para
su uso conforme la celda opera la masa
de la celda incrementa disminuye o
permanece igual justifica tu respuesta
de la parte de iu en términos de la
ecuación para la reacción total de la
celda entonces vamos a pensarlo un poco
la masa de la celda incrementa disminuye
o permanece igual bueno volvamos a la
reacción original esta es la reacción
total el zinc forma parte de la celda
metal aire así que eso contribuye a su
peso y después reacciona con el oxígeno
ok pero de dónde viene ese oxígeno pues
el oxígeno viene del aire y
esencialmente se incorpora con el zinc
entonces antes de la reacción el oxígeno
está en el aire pero después de la
reacción después de la reacción total se
incorpora con el zinc
el zinc se incorpora con el zinc para
formar óxido de zinc así que ahora el
oxígeno es parte de la celda parte
o mejor dicho contribuye al peso de las
celdas contribuye
contribuye al peso de la celda no
contribuye antes de la reacción sino
después de la reacción entonces la masa
y el peso aumenta vamos a escribirlo
aumenta
y en la parte en la segunda parte
necesitamos justificar nuestra respuesta
en términos de una ecuación para la
reacción total de la celda
entonces déjenme escribir la reacción
total de la celda dos moléculas de zinc
reaccionan con una molécula de oxígeno
molecular o dos para producir dos
moléculas de óxido de zinc
bueno lo que podemos decir de esto es
que no formaba parte de la celda antes
de la reacción no es parte de la celda
antes de la reacción
porque viene del aire antes de la
reacción y entonces esto forma parte de
la celda después de la reacción parte
de la celda
después
de la reacción
después de la reacción
entonces podemos decir que el oxígeno el
oxígeno proviene del aire del aire
para ser incorporado
al óxido de zinc
y que contribuye al peso bueno a la masa
de la celda que contribuye
a la masa
massa de la celda
ok nos quedó bastante bien ahora pasemos
al inciso c la celda zinc aire fue
tomada desde la cima de una montaña
donde la presión del aire es baja el
potencial de la celda será alto bajo o
igual al potencial de la celda a una
altura menor justifica la respuesta de
la primera parte con base en la ecuación
de la reacción total de la celda y la
información de arriba bueno vamos a
escribir nuevamente la reacción total de
la celda
tenemos dos moléculas de zinc más una
molécula de oxígeno molecular
esto se nos va a grabar en la memoria
para cuando terminemos porque la escribo
mucho
y se producen dos óxidos de zinc
entonces qué pasará si vamos a la cima
de una montaña donde la presión del aire
es baja bueno en total habría pocas
moléculas de aire pero eso significa que
tendremos menos moléculas de oxígeno
entonces podemos decir que la presión
parcial del oxígeno será menor la
presión parcial de este reactivo es
menor presión parcial porque hay menos
moléculas de oxígeno disponibles en el
aire para reaccionar con las moléculas
de zinc o simplemente como vimos en las
reacciones parciales que analizamos
pocas moléculas del aire reaccionarán
con moléculas de agua y con los
electrones que vienen del circuito
entonces tendremos pocas moléculas
disponibles para que ocurra esta
reacción y podemos decir que la presión
parcial
la presión parcial del reactivo bueno
puede ser presión parcial o
concentración es decir que hay menos
reactivos presión parcial o
concentración menor
entonces
entonces menor potencial de la celda hay
menor potencial de la celda
y creo que empecé al revés porque esta
es la parte 2 pero en la parte 1 es
menor el potencial de la celda es menor
es muy importante entender el concepto
de esto recuerden cuando analizamos la
reacción parcial que es lo que ocurre en
el cátodo bueno vamos a ver tenemos al
oxígeno que proviene del aire que se
filtra en esta sustancia porosa y cuando
las moléculas de o2 chocan con el agua y
entran los electrones se juntan y
reaccionan para formar hidróxido ahora
si tenemos menos es decir si nos
encontramos a una altura menor habrá
mucho más oxígeno y tendremos una
presión parcial más alta de oxígeno
molecular entonces tendremos muchas
moléculas disponibles para que reaccione
pero si nos encontramos a una altura
mayor tendremos pocas moléculas pocas
moléculas y por lo tanto tendremos una
presión parcial menor de oxígeno o
también lo podemos ver como una
concentración menor
y geno en los poros así será más difícil
que esta reacción ocurra y podríamos
pensar en una situación extrema qué pasa
si nos encontramos a una altura super
elevada por ejemplo si nos vamos al
espacio y hay muy poco oxígeno o incluso
nada de oxígeno pues entonces todas las
reacciones se detendrán